ce sont pas moins de soixante douze
incendies qui embrasent depuis lundi
plusieurs zones situées dans le nord de
l'algérie dont disent rien que pour la
willaya de tizi ouzou en grande kabylie
une région montagneuse à l'est de la
capitale selon le dernier communiqué du
ministère de l'intérieur plusieurs
civils et militaires auraient succombé
aux flammes le ministre de l'intérieur
qui avance lui la piste criminelle face
à ce drame la solidarité s'organise que
ce soit sur le plan local ou
international le président tunisien kaïs
saïd a appelé son homologue algérien
monsieur teboul pour lui offrir de
l'aide en matière d'hélicoptères
bombardiers d'eau l'algérie qui fait
face actuellement à une troisième vague
de coronavirus particulièrement
foudroyante notamment en raison de la
propagation rapide du variante delta le
pays qui peine également à faire
décoller sa campagne de vaccination
seulement 1,7 pour cent de la population
est complètement vaccinés sur 44
millions d'algériens -2 8% avait déjà
reçu une première dose plus de sept mois
après le début de la campagne de
vaccination